okay
me
good good evening everybody
we'll start in in just a few seconds
we'll allow councillor evans to get back
to his chair
uh joe can i just check about the
webcast
i believe the meeting is being webcast
chair thank you very much
okay so good evening everybody
um and as joe has just mentioned um the
meeting is being webcast
uh this evening so welcome to everybody
and to this meeting of the executive and
before we start there were just a couple
of observations that i wanted to make
um the first is that this room
is quite a difficult room for me to um
to navigate with my eyesight so i'm just
going to ask everybody to be a little
bit patient with me because i can't
actually see where anybody is
so counselor ross is going to assist me
in identifying who people are but if
for some reason we've missed you and
there is something that you wanted to
come in
um and ask then um please
do just um give us a shout if i've not
um
brought you in by the time we're about
to move on and
the second point i wanted to make really
is
just a gentle reminder and that this
is a meeting of the executive um
how i propose to take um the the
business this evening
um is we'll work through the agenda as
we normally would
um and from members of the executive
um i will be inviting comments and
questions
but more broadly i will just be inviting
questions of clarity and from people who
are not members of the executive
and that's really in the interest of
time because we have got an incredibly
busy agenda um and if it feels as though
we're not
um able to to move through the agenda
um in a way that we need to then i will
very politely just move people forward
and
okay so item one on the agenda is to
note
attendances and i would like to note
um apologies from counsellor
andrew weston and from councillor
whittem as well are there any other
apologies at all
not seen any other apologies um
item two is questions from members of
the public
and we haven't been notified of any
questions from members of the public
um item three is declarations of
interest are there any declarations of
interest at all this evening
no um and item
for any matters from
council or the overview and scrutiny
committees
um councillor acton please
thank you chair it's only really to let
the executive
know that the three separate scrutiny
committees have met
during the last month and looked at
developing a program for the coming year
so obviously there will be some items
there where we'll be
asking executive members to come along
and
senior officers as well so thank you
thank you councillor acton um item
number five is the section 75 framework
partnership
agreement and that's councillor harding
please
thank you uh chair this report is for
um noting by the executive and to
approve
the proposals um contained within the
section 75 partnership agreement
where we're now formalizing the funding
set out in 21 22.
i'm delighted in this report this is the
first time that we've got
some opportunity to work on learning
disabilities and
we are to approve the proposal to
delegate authority the corporate
director for adults
i'm pleased to bring this report the
better care fund and improved better
care fund
gives us an opportunity to work closely
with the ccg
to improve outcomes around health and
social care
for residents of trafford thank you
chair
apologies um councillor harding um thank
you very much
um are there any questions or comments
from
members of the executive
no and are there any questions of
clarity from members
more broadly
um so the report is for noting and for
approval is it approved hi
thank you um item number six
um is the um
is i know it's myself um
is the high needs capital investment
report
so i'm assuming that
members of the executive have read the
report so i won't spend too much time
um introducing it but the report sets
out proposals for the annual
allocation of the high needs capital
provision to carry out work to improve
the facilities and expand provision
for pupils with special educational
needs and disabilities
it also notes the completion of previous
send capital schemes
and trafford's allocation for these is
just over
1.6 million and we are aware and it does
say in the report
that we do have very limited capacity to
meet
increasing demand for places in both
primary and secondary settings
in the future but we are committed to
increasing provision
where we can within trafford
so the the report details the model
of small specialist classes and within
mainstream primary and secondary schools
in trafford
and recognises the success of this model
in meeting autism spectrum and
communication
needs and the report details the
proposals
for the schemes and
also details the consultation that's
taken place so the recommendations
are on page one of the report um and i
am pleased to recommend them to the
executive
are there any questions or comments from
members of the executive
any questions of clarity from members
more broadly um
and uh councillor but please
yes thank you chad uh it's point on
uh paddy pipe one actually when it's
high needs provision capital allocation
grant this 1.67 million
is from the government which indicates
it can be used towards
primary and secondary school places so i
don't understand
why there is the need to say it's not
ring-fenced
i mean it says needs must
um so i think that's a technical point
from
um of how the funding is allocated so
i don't think it's technically ring
fenced by the government that that's
what you
have to use that capital funding for i'm
going to ask karen the question
um in a minute but i think regardless of
whether it's ring fenced or not that
certainly that that would be what we are
using the funding
for so i think it's probably a technical
question of of
of how that funding's allocated i'll
just
check with karen if that's the case
karen
yeah can everybody hear me yeah um
because it's high needs capital funding
um it is there to um address
any sufficiency issues we may have for
children and young people with send
so that's where we we allocate the
funding to make sure that we can create
the additional provision
based on um the increasing numbers of
children and young people with send
within the borough
so that's how how we target the funding
and how we utilize the funding
thanks karen um councillor
young um did you just want to
uh to come in there at all
i'm sorry i haven't been able to hear
anything
but i assume we're on item six now
um yes yes well i i did actually want to
say something i need to declare an
interest in a fish in
the beginning of this because i've
recently been working
within a small group to try and improve
facilities for autistic children in the
south of
trafford and i have had a lot of help
from
the executive members and council
officers in trafford
who have been really helpful and i did
want to say thank you to them
and i do welcome the recommendations
made in this report
because you're pretty much doing what we
were hoping
that you would do or trying to you know
come to the same
agreement you see the findings of the
consultation that you refer to in the
report
have actually demonstrated that there is
a need
for more small specialist classes
in trafford and especially in the south
of trafford and especially for secondary
age
children because there are more
facilities available in trafford
for the primary age to children
and um
secondary age children particularly
the autistic children in south trafford
are currently faced with a very long
commute into school
particularly if they're fortunate at
staff
to get a place in one of the specialist
classes
for children with additional needs and
it's it's difficult what it is the
problem why
we're wanting if we can get places in
the south of the borough
is that these children with with special
needs
usually make their friends from the
children
in the same school that they go to and
if they live in the south of the borough
but they're all their friends are coming
maybe from the north or from other parts
it's
very difficult for them to go and
arrange play dates and things of that
sort
so the one final thing i wanted to ask
was
i know that plans are being made for
new housing developments in trafford
and if there are any plans for a new
school
to be built anywhere or for major
refurbishments
of any existing schools hopefully in the
south of the borough but actually
anywhere in travelled
could this also could you bear it in the
backs of your minds
that it would be helpful if there were
possibilities
put into the plans for these specialist
classes
to be incorporated into the school
buildings
anyway thank you for letting me speak
thank you
councillor young and i'm sorry that you
can't hear it it's quite difficult i
think
to hear um in this room the the accused
the acoustics are quite tricky um so
um i did allow that ques that statement
even though it wasn't um
fully uh a question because you'd
perhaps not not heard that before but
um thank you for those comments which
are really helpful and we will feed
those through
um counsellor blackburn please
thank you deputy leader um out of the
um the main 280 million pound provision
how was our wedge
calculated how on sort of what basis
did you know did we get that amount of
money
um also um in point 2.4
it's noted that there are nine primary
schools that cater for
ssc could you at some point let me know
which schools they are and thirdly
um as no expression of interest has been
received
from primary schools in the south of the
borough
do we know why is it is it due to
building capacity or lack of specialism
in some of the schools do do we know why
that there's been no
take-up thank you thank you
councillor blackburn and they are um
very good questions actually
um the first one um i'm going to
um defer to karen um to help me answer
that question because i'm not sure
how that's worked out but i know that
there are formulas that that work
that through um in terms of
um provision in um
i would i will get the information to
you about which schools
um the specialist classes are
in um in terms of the um the primary
schools
i think there are probably numerous
reasons and i know we're really keen to
to support a school in the south of the
borough um
to to develop a small specialist class
because they are
really um you know they do
work so um but i'll just bring karen in
if there's anything karen can can add to
my answer please
thank you councillor heinz yes um in
terms of the allocation of the funding
it will be based on some of the data
that we've submitted around
the number of children with with scnd
and particularly those children with an
ehc plan
um so there's a kind of a formula
proportionate um allocation made on the
basis of that data that's been submitted
in terms of the small specialist classes
i think there are nine small specialist
classes but not necessarily in nine
different primary schools
so some of our primary schools actually
will have numerous small specialist
classes within them as well
so i don't know whether that perhaps
needs a bit of clarification within the
report as well
but i can give you the names of those
places where
they do actually have a small specialist
class allocated
so at the moment we have a hall primary
which is an academy actually we have
barton cluff
we have well field infants and welfield
juniors
and we have moreland's juniors as well
so that's where the
um allocation of primary schools most
small specialist classes are based
um councillor hines is absolutely right
very often the the challenges that some
of our schools
face in in hosting a small specialist
class is literally the physical space
both internally as well as externally
and certainly as as as class numbers and
the student population has continued to
grow
that can be something that proves a
barrier
and obviously when we do allocate a
small specialist class we tend to try
and wrap around
the support that's required as well to
help meet the needs of those children in
the classes so
again if the primary schools can't
actually meet that
uh demand that that's required that does
tend to
present a bit of a barrier um in
encouraging the schools to actually host
a small specialist class but
you know we'll certainly continue to
consider that as we continue to plan
going forward
what i have asked is of our offices is
to really look at creating a sufficiency
strategy so that we can really begin to
see the growth of the population as it
comes through
so we can make sure we allocate the
funding accordingly so that's something
we can certainly report on as
we develop that piece of work okay thank
you
thank you um karen and thank you
everybody for your
questions um i'm not seeing any more
hands um doesn't mean there aren't any
but counselor ross
advises me there are not um so the
report is for approval is it approved
i thank you um so
moving on to item number seven
which is places for everyone um
and this is counselor right please
thank you chair i am delighted to bring
this report to council which is a
strategic plan to deal with the housing
crisis across greater manchester
and provide guaranteed land for
employment helping the local economy
to grow following the kovid 19 pandemic
as i'm sure members are aware the
background for this plan is that in
trafford we simply do not have the
brownfield land supply available
to build the homes that we need both the
housing land availability assessment
and the call for sites have confirmed
that we have and will continue to take a
brownfield first approach but this is
simply not enough
we have a housing crisis in trafford and
grey to manchester
the average home costs over eight times
the average salary
there are thousands of people waiting
for social housing and we cannot and
will not turn a blind eye to this
this plan will see some land release
from the greenbelt in order to meet our
housing targets
and deal with the housing crisis however
this planning can pro
in comparison to previous iterations
sees a significant reduction
oh sorry apologies uh however this
planning comparison
to previous iterations sees a
significant reduction in greenbelt loss
in the original gmsf plan from 2016
not just did we have significantly more
loss at both carrington and timberley
wedge
but we also had loss at flixton as
members will be aware
flixton has been removed as part of the
negotiations with greater manchester
and there have been significant
reductions across both carrington and
timperley
72 hectares in carrington and 14
hectares in
saved in temporally in the current
places for everyone plan
this equates to a reduction of circa 40
percent in greenbelt loss over the last
five years
as members will be aware without a
collaborative approach with the other
eight gm authorities now excluding
stockport of course
we will be required to find land for a
further 5 000 homes
this would inevitably lead to even
further greenbelt loss
as we simply do not have land within the
urban area that could meet this need
whilst most of the headlines surrounding
gmsf and now places for everyone have
been dominated by housing
and setting a new greenbelt boundary
there are other
very positive parts of plan which which
are worth noting
firstly is the wall councillor who
represents carrington and the nearby
communities of partington and southwest
this plan provides the framework to
further support and enhance the
regeneration of partington and
carrington itself
partington is the most isolated part of
trafford and one of the most deprived
one of the key issues faced in
partington is a lack of access to good
jobs
across trafford and the wider gm
conurbation
the transport links are simply not good
enough
the public transport provision is not
fit for purpose
as per the report this plan works
alongside the gm transport plan of 2040
which proposes to enhance sustainable
modes of travel and improve upon the
existing transport network
whilst making travel more sustainable
through better public transport
and walking and cycling routes the road
network that connects parties in the
to the rest of greater manchester is
simply not good enough
manchester road is simply not up to the
task
to will that to enable the regeneration
of partington and alleviate the issues
faced by villages in carrington
a new road is required the options for
that new row will become clearer later
this year however
let's be clear we cannot have
sustainable and better public transport
without a road which is fit for purpose
we cannot alleviate the issues faced by
people who live on manchester road
without taking heavy traffic off this
road
secondly and this is not and this list
is not exhaustive
places for everyone supports the gm
vision to be carbon neutral by 2028
enhances the protection of green open
spaces in places like sail west
there are also more detailed policies on
mitigating the impact of climate change
as members will be aware we are at the
regulation 19 stage of this plan which
means we are now consulting on the legal
soundness of the plan
the details of which are in the report
i'll move the report thank you chair
thank you councillor right and apologies
for
um the the mike situation at the
beginning there
are there any questions or comments from
members of the
executive no
and are there any questions of clarity
from members more broadly
uh councillor morgan please
thank you chad i presume you can hear me
unless you'd let me know otherwise
um thank you um so there's another some
questions for
um for council right there i know you
might um ask richard
um given the the ones i'm asking so 45
there's 45
affordable homes in the timberwolves and
15
in um carrington in terms of for example
a three-bedroom
house what would that amount to in terms
of
cost um and the council's the second
question i'll do it all in one go
um states that it's got a brownfield
first policy so what are there any legal
um
position in the pfe documentation that
when the green belt is released
if there's any limitations on housing
before
the brownfield lands developed before
the
carrington relief road or typically
wedge spines developed or any primary
schools are built
and the new davenport green metro link
is in the south of the wedge
um it's at least 20 minutes walk from
hail barnes
in my ward i know davenport green is
also my award
so exactly how many people are estimated
to be using that metro link
from either hailbounds village the well
green estate
or any of the two regions be other
regions being proposed in the wedge
thank you um
counselor right would you like to
respond thank you chair thank you
council morgan for the
question on um questions one and three
i'm gonna pass to richard question two i
actually can't remember what you asked
or apologies could i ask you to
repeat that please it's all right sorry
about that
um are there any anything legally
within the places for everyone document
which prevents
a developer the moment that the
greenbelt
land is released that they cannot
develop on it
before a brownfield land is used first
b the relief road or the tympani wedge
spine road are developed
or c the new schools which are promised
within the documents are built
or is there nothing within it which
which prevents the developer from
theoretically doing it and given that
i know he has has very strong views
about developers
um um and sometimes their decision
making we appreciate if there's any
legal
constraints in it thank you thanks
counselor morgan i'm just going to
quickly i can answer part of question
two
in relation to the carrington relief
road there are restrictions
on developers building homes
in carrington and the surrounding areas
already within as part of the planning
process
um because we it's recognized within the
current planning system that we can't
actually
um sustainably build any more homes
until we have some improvements in the
road infrastructure
i'll pass over to richard for questions
one and three and maybe to fill in the
details about question two
however thanks
hello thank you can you hear me okay
um so in terms of the affordable housing
um the the policy is set that the
majority of the affordable housing
that's delivered will be either be
affordable rent or social rent
those affordable rent is defined by the
government as 80
of market rent that's how that that is
set so that will be dependent on the
market rent at that point when the
properties are
built and um social rent is also
set in accordance with rent formula
which is circus 60
of market rent at the richard thanks
sorry i'm sure because it's just that i
can clarify my question
but if for example now what would simply
wedge for example at 45
what um affordable housing what would if
what would affordable housing be in the
tim
in south timperley hale barnes at the
moment
uh i'll have to come back to you because
i don't know off the top of my head what
market rents are in
uh in in hale but i can come back to you
on that but it is in accordance with
government policy on the brownfield
first policy some of these are issues
that will
are set within places for everyone some
are things that will come through
in development management policies so as
a
as a starter in general once land is
identified as suitable for
development then that land can come
forward at any any time during the plan
period the brownfield first approach
sets out that to minimize the amount of
green belt land at release but what the
plan sets
is that there is an insufficient
brownfield land
identified within traffic and within gm
to deliver
against the housing nice target that the
government has
given to us within the within the
development management process there are
then restrictions
that can come in around when development
takes place in accordance with delivery
of other infrastructure so as
as councillor wright said that's already
in place in terms of current and relief
load and we'll be looking at similar
things to come through
elsewhere and other developments so
there are there
are grampian conditions the conditions
we can put through the planning process
that helps control
the development of land against
development of infrastructure
and on your final question um which was
around
number of people in access to the
proposed metro link at davenport green i
think i'll have to come back to you with
an answer on
on that
thank you um richard um and
councillor coggins please
thank you chair um i think uh davis
asked several of what i wanted to ask
and just some more clarification um
around the using the green belt first
unfortunately my um laptop hasn't
managed to communicate with the
external world here so i'm i'm managing
without my notes and
um using my phone um my understanding
and
as i say i had the details on my laptop
um is that oldham
and the northeast corridor has some sort
of exemption to the
not to um the process that richard was
just referring to where basically
once it's released it is all released
and that the northeast corridor
seemed to have some kind of exemption
where it
really wasn't going to build on green
belt until other bits
were used but as i say unfortunately
i've not got the notes available
if we could get some clarity on that
please
richard
yeah we'll come back to you on that
thanks
thank you and uh councillor new grosh
please
well firstly my apologies for my
lateness to this meeting
now both councillors have raised the one
question the the achilles heel of your
entire thing is brownfield first
and yet no protection at all not one
little bit
so my question is why not why haven't
you got some protection
for the sixteen thousand brownfield
sites that we've already identified
and also follow-up question what work
have you done
contacting local communities to identify
additional brownfield sites such as
the atlantic business park of ultram
that could be adapted for housing
thank you for your question uh council
new gross um
two two things to respond to that with
really uh first of all
uh we have um a we we have
we have as you've already stated sixteen
thousand units within the brownfield
land within brownfield land that have
gonna hopefully come forward for
development um but let's be frank about
this
we are in a housing crisis uh we need we
need to build homes
we can't just hope for brownfield land
to come forward
people are homeless we need to do
something about it
it's as simple as that um
sorry cancer nuggets can you just repeat
your second question because i've
forgotten in my um
my response well i mean 16
000 homes would solve the homeless
problem uh in trafford
um what outreach have we done to the
communities
to identify brownfield sites for example
atlantic business park yeah so we've
we've done a call for sites
which clearly identified that there was
not enough brownfield land
available and we have also taken part of
course
in the and i'll just find the details of
it the housing land availability
assessment
which has been published on the website
which clearly identifies that there
isn't enough brownfield land
for the amount of homes that are
required in this borough um
but the facts are uh councillor new
gross that
we are in a housing crisis so we need to
deal with that housing crisis
so however we come and do that if that
involves the release of greenbelt then
we need to do something about it
the majority of people um below 35 in
this borough cannot afford to buy a
property
and we've got to do something about that
there are thousands of people on our
waiting lists and we've got to do
something about that it's as simple as
that
thank you
thank you councillor right thank you
cancer the new grush
um counselor uh councillor blackburn
please
thank you deputy leader um with regard
to the impact kovid's had
on working arrangements will there be
any reduction
in the estimated office space
requirement for the future
as some people will choose to work at
home and some businesses
will choose for their workers to work at
home in the future
thank you
you councillor blackburn i'm that
that'll be something that can can be
discussed as part of the consultation
um and obviously um all consultation
responses will come
will will be taken into account on that
fact um but yes it's something that
certainly will be considered over the
next few months
thank you uh councillor evans please
thank you thank you council hines deputy
leader um
i just want to expand a little bit on uh
councillor blackburn's question
um what effort went in postcovid to
researching and actually your comment
that it can be taken into consideration
as part of the consultation
it's my understanding this is not a
consultation there can be some
representations
but fundamentally this is it and this is
what's going forward
and just one more concern really
um councillor goggins mentions um
the olden and other areas may have an
exemption
the fact that we don't have an answer to
that and this executive is going to take
a decision
on this and accept this as approved
and we actually at council we don't even
get to discuss the content
and the consultation you are wrong will
not take
those things into consideration how can
you take that decision
um counselor right thank you
just in relation to your first point
councillor evans the consultation's a
regulation 19 consultation so you're
able to comment on the following
whether the plan has been positively
prepared whether the plan is justified
whether the plan is effective and
whether the plan is consistent with
national policy
so as part of the office requirements
that council blackburn mentioned we
could potentially put it in as justified
as part of the reason that you may want
to comment on that and just in relation
to the other question that you've
asked about whether there is any
protection for the greenbelt
we have already stated as part of this
that we have exhausted our brownfield
land supply
and at some point we are going to need
to build the homes that are required in
this borough
thank you
thank you um okay so i'm not seeing
any further questions
from anybody no um okay so
um the report is for approval
from the executive is it approved hi
thank you um so
uh moving on to item number eight
um the clean air plan and counselor
i'd said ads head will introduce this
for us
thank you uh thank thank you
deputy leader can you hear me all right
is that coming through i think that
it's hard to get the microphone close
for us not going on yeah uh the report
before us this evening is probably
one of the most important reports in
relation to the public health agenda
we have seen in a very long time the
report is very comprehensive
and details a history of the work as the
scheme has been developed over the last
few years
as you may recall at the outset the
government was taken to court on three
occasions for failing to comply
with exceedences in national dioxide
and they passed this onto local
government to sort out
rather than work in collaboration with
us to do this work
however they have still controlled many
aspects of how this work can be managed
including the vehicle categorization
which has been a problem earlier on
when we had taxes another saying
they wanted some exemptions but the
scheme of a b c
and d is quite clearly laid out and they
cannot be altered anywhere in the
country
and that was a point of contention
they've also included
the types of roads that can be included
now as you may be aware
the local motorway network which runs
through all the areas in the hearts of
greater manchester
is simply outside the scope of this work
yet it's clearly
one of the main problems of this and and
even now it is
um counsellor i said i'm so sorry to
interrupt you do you think you could you
move just slightly closer to the mic
again
i'm so sorry thank you thank you yeah
uh so yes thank you uh definitely
yeah uh shows you where the motorway
network remains outside the scope of air
control
whilst no doubt is a clear contributor
to this problem
and this remains an area of concern to
everyone locally modelling has shown the
extent of the health related problems
and that this work could help save the
equivalent of some twelve hundred like
twelve hundred thousand
one thousand two hundred lives each year
around greater manchester due to the
effects of pollution
as well as many other respiratory
illnesses
i attended my first briefing on the
clean air proposals and plan around
three years ago
and i'm well aware of actually having
seen the scheme
evolve and develop during that time i
can say that many different types of
modelling
and proposals have been looked at before
this particular scheme was arrived at
the proposals before tonight will bring
us into compliance within the time scale
set out
in ministerial directions and trafford
is likely to be one of the first to
reach compliance
in greater manchester in developing the
kc scheme
each category of vehicle class has to be
justified
and to be shown to be included in it how
it can actually help
to bring forward the day of compliance
to the earliest
if we could not show and justify this we
could leave ourselves open to legal
challenge
the report details the consultation
that the issues have been raised and the
responses
also to those matters and these are all
set out in full detail in section 6.
section 7 details the final proposals as
they affect each vehicle class
and includes extensive detail and
information
around each type of vehicle setting out
the charges that would apply to those
vehicles
the money is available for retrofit and
vehicle replacement
i'm sure most members will find this
really helpful should they receive
inquiries from
residents in finishing i would like to
thank all officers both at tfgm and
across above us for the amount of work
that has gone into this
it's certainly the largest piece of work
i personally have ever come across and
they've always done this in a way that
can
easily be understood by everyone and i'd
also like to pay tribute to andrew
weston
as the gem lead on this who has helped
take the government to task on more than
one occasion
and particularly pursued the matter of a
hardship fund which is something we all
feel strongly about
as we now move into implementation phase
implementation phase even
there's clearly a lot to do however at
the end of this work
the health benefits this will bring will
be enormous and i'm sure the residents
around trafford and gm more widely will
welcome the cleaner air that this work
will bring thank you
thank you very much councillor adsed for
for moving this for us this evening
um are there any comments or questions
from members of the
executive no
um and any questions of clarity
more broadly
um councillor evans please
thank you very much deputy leader um i
i've got several questions but one key
question which will ask first and i
would like to include a monitor
officer perhaps to answer i believe this
report
is specifically misleading
and tfgm have either either been
totally incompetent in their due
diligence
or at worst intentionally misleading
councillor evans that's that that's
quite a bold statement
it doesn't it doesn't sound like a
question of clarity
the question of clarity is
on page 105 it suggests
that a grant of five thousand pound for
retrofit to lgbs
will be available up until
probably a week ago tfgm and councillor
weston and what shame is not here
tonight
we're arguing that the market would step
up it has only come as clarity
today and i would almost say to the
executive member
what percentage of vans on our road like
goods vehicles transits escorts
kangas etc does he consider might be
eligible for retrofit
and what would be a threshold a
reasonable threshold for our traders
florists plumbers winter cleaners
um i'm not sure would counselor said
would you like to answer that question
or would you like us to take that away
yeah thank you uh definitely i think
we'll take that away uh
okay so let's be clear that figure is 90
90 of our traders will not be able to
retrofit
they will have to go into debt and so
the information in this report
is inadequate for you to take a decision
counselor evans i'm so sorry
this is it's not a question of you've
asked your question of clarity which we
will come back
to you may i refer this to the
monitoring officer because i do not
believe that this report is detailed
enough to allow you as an executive to
answer it
um councillor freeman would you like to
come in there
thank you councillor evans was at the
same briefing the majority of us were at
last week
and has raised this this report is going
to full council on wednesday council
evans
when you have the opportunity to debate
to debate what you want to debate you
have been asked to provide
questions of clarity not a full debate
and we're not having a full debate on it
in this
room tonight it's for council on
wednesday thank you
i'm not asking for the debate i'm so
sorry councillor evans
this if we could start going to and fro
it it does turn into a little bit of a
debate
could i just bring councillor patel in
please
thank you sorry i was just struggling
there um just
following on from councillor freeman i
was at that same
uh briefing with tfgm and councillor
weston
and uh councillor evans question was
answered in quite detail
um they i think that the bulk of the the
gist of it is that no one has ever
suggested that retrofit is the silver
bullet that will
um resolve all the all the potential
issues for businesses but it but that
that technology is evolving um and that
we're doing our best
to ensure that those that can access
retrofit do access retrofit
i think the um council evans's efforts
should really be focused on
lobbying the government to to produce
and and to stand up for businesses
through a welfare fund
that we've increasingly asked him to do
and i doubt that he's ever
made an approach to to his government
thank you
i'm just going to ask i think councillor
radz had just wanted to come back in
actually to
uh to respond to the the question
councillor ad said thank you
thank you deputy leader i think i've
also recalled the presentation this week
i'm aware that
the email that uh council evans received
today sets out clearly
that the work of and lotus retrofit with
the exception of some of the buses and
so forth it's actually all fairly new
technology
and it's evolving and it will involve
over the coming period what we do need
from government
is to actually give those companies and
organizations the ability
and finances to actually help support
retrofit isn't just greater manchester
that's got
these problems with retrofit or it's not
a problem it's a new technology he need
it's a nationwide problem and indeed if
he would be good enough to actually
contact
his government and actually get them to
actually put resources into actually
supporting
the companies and funding them and
giving them the necessary work to
actually
get the scheme off the ground that will
really help but it is a new and emerging
technology
council so i don't know you made all
these questions a couple of times now
i'm sure we'll hear the game on
wednesday
but the reality is as i've pointed out
it is something that's going to happen
you've been told this and whilst they
got some of the figures now those
percentages that develop might be
relevant now
for some retrofit it might not relevant
in three months six months
nine months 12 months as that will
change and more companies will be
getting onto this
as they can actually find different ways
to electro fit these
and i think many more vehicles will come
onto it council so i mean
you've been told this so i don't know
why you keep repeating yourself thank
you
um so just just before i bring you back
in for another question
uh councillor evans i'm just going to
bring in um
the monitoring officer because you have
made some
um comments really that you've addressed
to
um to jane bring jane and thank you
thank you um i think the thing is in the
first instance
the um position tonight is the executive
is being asked to recommend
the plan to uh council for approval so
the matter the
the actual approval of the plan sits
with council itself it will be a council
decision
in terms of the report you've raised a
couple of issues in relation to the
report
and suggested that it doesn't provide
all the information
however it's quite clear from comments
that have been made by members of the
executive here
that they are aware of the fact that
there are issues that this is not
simply a
fits one-size-fits-all that there are
issues in terms of the retrofit policy
so those are
matters that are clearly within their
contemplation in any event
and i would suggest that if you do still
have concerns about those
we are following them up with tfgm
we can do so to get some greater clarity
but they are issues that you can raise
again in the council chamber if you
choose to do so
but i think the position is that tonight
the the executive is being asked
to consider the plan as it is set out in
this report before them
on the basis that the report is is
accurate
and on that basis then it would be
recommended to counsel
if there are any other issues or
concerns with the report
at that stage they can be raised in the
council chamber i think that's the most
appropriate way
to deal with it and in the meantime if
there are still any
ongoing issues that you have we can
endeavor to clarify the position on
those
ahead of the meeting on wednesday thanks
jane um that clarification is really
helpful
um councillor evans did you have another
question
thank you just standard clarification
questions um
the 2020 air quality management report
suggests one exceedance in 2020
that puts us 94 under the government
target
2019 council of western answered the
question um
in council a few months ago three
exceedences 84
under the target and zero in trafford
what targets
is the executive member suggesting we
are not meeting
in trafford let alone greater manchester
second question
page 88 of the report suggests 4 700
responses given there are 120 000
businesses in greater manchester
that's three percent what percent of
businesses
in trafford responded or even know
about this and then secondly thirdly
sorry
um where would you suggest these small
traders get
thirty thousand pound from in order to
fund a replacement vertical or pay
three thousand pound a year
um councillor said would you like to
respond to that question or
would would you like to respond um
as you will be aware it's not just
individual exceedances at any one point
in time it's exceedances over a long
period of time
so obviously uh we've been directed to
do this because
it's been estimated and the modelling
shown this clearly that without this
modeling
we would not be compliant in those
periods of time to come the modelling
has shown clearly
by the time we get to the period 2024
that we will comply
with the ministerial direction in that
so i can't really add much more
to that that's quite clear and that
information has been given out there and
i think that
animation should be in the report there
uh
um can you uh so other questions again
was actually i think one of them
can you clarify your questions council
because i'm having problems here and
writing things down here is
very bad here repeat your second
question
thank you and 4 700 businesses
responded that's three percent of the
businesses within gm
how many of those from were from
trafford
we'll have to come back
yeah we'll come back did you give us a
cut on your third on your final question
the 90 of businesses that are going to
be plunged into debt where do you
propose to get the 30 000 pounds to
replace a transit van from despite the
fact you're only going to give them
three and a half thousand
thank you i'll simply say in response to
that counselor one of the things we're
obviously looking at
is actually the hardship fund and i
think you do very well if you could
actually help support and lobby your
government for this
here's one of the key points there we
have been working very hard and ping's
pointed out that
we cannot solve every single problem
with all of this and we want to continue
this work
and ladies and just because we'll be the
report we'll be going through councils
and then we'll be moving to an
implementation phase it does not mean
that
that will be the end of the discussions
with companies businesses and the like
those discussions will be continuing and
we will help support in any way we can
but i think crucial to that obviously is
the retrofit it is the vehicle
replacement
and of course vehicle placement itself
does not simply uh
cover the cost of a whole vehicle we
understand that but however it is quite
clear that where that traffic can be
done and that will be increasing over a
period of time
that the uh it is actually older
vehicles that will not be capable of any
form of retrofit and that will be a
contribution to that and those older
vehicles themselves
will not be of particular high value but
ever however nevertheless
what we will continue to do is obviously
work with those companies and see if we
do it
and we could really help us assist if
you could uh help us
get support for this hardship fund that
remains one of the key areas that we
would like support for thank you
thank you a counselor rad said um
councillor morgan please
thank you deputy leader um so
it's an interesting report it's an
interesting way that
greater manchester has gone very
different to other other cities in terms
of
um its approach on this um and in some
ways it's both
um both too far and not far enough in
terms of i mean if you could look on
appendix 6
um the the city centre will still have
issues
um um in 2025 um where the biggest
amounts of issues are
um but i've got two questions that i and
i appreciate that
um um these might be already covered in
the documentation and apologies i wasn't
able to go to the briefing last monday
um but what percentage of vehicles which
currently
are um exceed the um the in terms of the
emissions
are going to be impacted by this scheme
because obviously
private vehicles won't and um for the
annual opex spend on the anpr machines
um another infrastructure how many
vehicles would you need to be paying the
charge in order to support the
infrastructure annual opex thank you
counselor i said did you want to respond
to that
yeah on the on the cameras and so forth
uh obviously uh
the the income itself isn't necessarily
to pay for the scheme as you would seen
in the report
is a charge to actually help support
compliance and it's been carefully
weighed out
to make sure that it's not too low so
that people simply willing to pay the
charge
or that is too high and it's actually
too onerous so we've been working with
government and others
to actually try and make sure the charge
is suitable and
and we've revived at that and i think
they charged that now you did mention
particularly
other authorities around the country and
and indeed yes
that's absolutely right that there are a
huge variation in numbers and types of
schemes
and different levels in fact some areas
have now come back said they actually
don't need that because they've reached
compliance
by some of the work they have done in
terms of uh
replacing buses and other work so i
think in that sense
that's quite clear but there are
problems in every part of the country
some of them have just got the problem
in city centres and therefore they do
not particularly need
a wider scheme like we have here so it
might be that if you're doing a small
area in a city centre yeah
some of them have done a c scheme some
have done a d scheme
but in greater manchester we're such a
huge county and our problems are
throughout the whole of the county
and i think just trying to say do
something in the city centre itself
would not work
and there may well be problems in the
coming period over the next few years
however
we are quite obviously where the city
centre will be taking measures and
working to actually see how that can be
alleviated
i believe there may be a number of
options around that what they can
actually look at
and indeed any work around that would
obviously involve trafford
in in that sense of it so there are
different schemes around gm
absolutely and what they are elsewhere
but i think what has shown clearly is
that this model
that has been worked on for the last few
years is the model that will work in gm
similar models around the country would
not work here
it's not something you can just simply
take off a shelf already made
like an oven ready meal something that
it has to be designed specifically for
what's done here
and as i pointed out in my comments
introducing it
and we've looked at various types of
schemes proposals all sorts of things
and and this is the one we set on
because it's the one that brings
compliance
in the shortest possible time and in
line we've been to sterile directions
was it anything else councillor morgan
thanks steve
um he didn't actually answer my question
um so my question was
for the operating expenditure for the
ampr machines
what number of vehicles would need to be
need to pay the charge in order to pay
that
so i imagine that you will have an
excess in the first year but what level
of decline would you be able to take
before you weren't able then you'd have
to take that out of general spend
from the council expenditure or tfgm
expenditure
so i couldn't catch all of that because
it's a coming backwards forward
but uh particularly uh on the on the
cameras there is no spend
there is no limit on the spend on it
isn't the case we're going to get the
income and that'll pay for all of it
this is funded by government and and the
scheme will be in place
until we've actually reached compliance
so just to confirm steve both the
capital expenditure and the operating
expenditure
are funded by central government
apologies if this was covered last
monday and i wasn't there apologies that
was covered just to confirm
operating expenditure is covered by
central government
the government has given us a
contribution to actually set up the
schemes
and and and that we should get the
running cost will be covered by the
income
but what level would the income have to
drop before you couldn't cover the
running costs
i'm not sure i think we'd have to come
back to you on that yeah it sounds like
quite a technical
question i don't know if richard did you
have anything to add to that or should
we come back
on that because it does sound like it's
something it's it's quite a technical
question so
we'll we'll respond to you um
at a later date um
i've got counselor chalking please
thank you deputy leader i just wanted to
clarify and apologize if this was
covered last week i couldn't get onto
the briefing
the report does state that private cars
aren't going to be covered by this and
it goes into great detail as to why it's
not going to work
at the current time but is the ambition
of the leadership
of greater manchester under trafford to
cover private vehicles
and if so are we going to see greater
manchester wide or are we going to see
it
at the local level around say stop paul
that sort of thing um just can we just
clarify that because it's going to be a
concern for everyone
uh when this eventually comes in
so uh definitely i can't understand
completely what he was saying that
wasn't very clear
i mean what i will say obviously uh i'm
not quite sure whether all it looks
because i couldn't
understand some of it but obviously uh
we did consider it a a
d scheme but it is not necessary because
adding uh a casd scheme into the mix
here
would not bring forward the date of
compliance any sooner and as i did
allude to earlier we have to justify
every vehicle class that's actually
included within the scheme
and if we unnecessarily include one we
can be subject to legal challenge on
that one because
that they would not be help bring
forward that compliance date
so obviously does that answer your
question
in part thank you what i was trying to
say was if that doesn't work are we then
going to
go down further at the route of applying
it to private cars in the future
uh and if so are we doing that greater
manchester wide or
is that going to be looked at on a more
localized level
thank you just on that one there uh the
compliance uh the model as we've shown
children that
as it currently it's been worked on for
the last few years it's very clear we
will reach compliance within the stable
directions are set out in that one
obviously it will be monitored
and if problems happens we have to come
back but the model is quite clear and
very comprehensive
and it's in line with what's done
elsewhere in the country i have no
reason to believe that the modern will
show anything different in that sense of
it
but however it will be clearly monitored
as it sets out over the
next couple of years thank you thank you
um councillor blackburn please
thank you deputy leader where will the
charging monies go to
and what will it be spent on
thank you but yeah it could lead that
leader just to
believe on that one obviously if you've
seen the report uh
two pounds goes towards uh the
government to actually funding the way
in which the scheme is administered
and the rest of it although to be worked
out completely it can be used to help
help transport issues around greater
manchester over the coming years
thank you
um yes thanks for your questions um and
thank you
councillor ad said um i think
for me i would just want to to add
really that
counselor rad's head did outline um when
he introduced the report
some incredibly damning
um statistics and and i don't like to
even use the word
statistics when what you're describing
is
the number of people who die from
respiratory
um difficulties um and
what is really clear is that it is
vital um that we implement these
proposals and that we make them work
across greater manchester
um and i think some of the the questions
that
that we've had this evening um
have had a premise behind them that have
made me feel as though
um what we're saying is that is is that
um this isn't something that um
potentially people
um who've raised some of the questions
necessarily support but what i would say
is that it's absolutely vital that we do
support these proposals
um the proposals um
are for approval as set out in the paper
and as explained by the monitoring
officer are they approved
hi thank you moving on
then to item number nine
um councillor ross please
thank you deputy leader um so i'm
presenting the
period to uh budget monitoring report um
it's obviously still
very early in the year and this is our
best estimate
based on patterns we've seen we're
currently forecasting an overspend
of 2.2 million some underlying figures
to support that would be the
833 000 pressure in children's
placements
um and we're seeing more complex cases a
continued loss of income from the place
direction that's largely fed in thanks
to the um the ongoing covert situation
and we look like um looking at our
ability to
find replacement investment
opportunities as part of the strategic
investment um
choices that we make um we also have to
consider a
pay award which will be coming from
contingency once that is agreed on
and as part of this exercise we've also
introduced at the back of the
report a rag rating where we're looking
through each of our
savings and income proposals for the
year and just
looking at a red anger green as to
whether we will achieve them or not
so again i'd stress it's period two this
is still early in the year we are very
mindful of the budget and the pressures
that local government across the country
continues to face
and we will be monitoring this very very
carefully
i'm happy to take any questions
thank you councillor ross are there any
questions or comments from members of
the executive
no and
um questions of clarity for more broadly
and um counselor bots please
thank you chair this is for the exec
member council ross
item more this for business rates
and power five i mean the first sentence
says
yes we are it's difficult to project and
prove
uh prove which is prone to variation you
know the the
business rate so government has provided
support to retail
hospitality and leisure businesses
so why are you now determined to
undermine
the recovery process by nobling their
life support
their customers by increasing parking
charges just at a time when
the businesses are trying to recover
from the covered restrictions
thank you thank you that's a very
interesting question um i mean
first things first not every business
where there's a car park um
you know you know there's a certain
place for example in my own ward where
there's
free parking for a set period so for
stratford mao
um you'll be aware of the very tight um
situation we find ourselves in and we
have to take difficult decisions
and one of those decisions was to
increase car parking charges make them
uniform
um across the borough and that is
something that we stand by because we
have to balance a budget at the end of
the day
not everyone uses a car to go to the
shops and we should be encouraging more
sustainable ways of
of people walking cycling using active
travel
using public transport so i do just
completely reject the premise of your
question
thank you councillor ross um
any other questions
no um and the report is for noting
is it noted i thank you
um and it's over to you again councillor
ross
for um the treasury management report
thank you deputy leader this is the
annual out turn report which has also
been presented to accounts and audit
committee for scrutiny
last week as part of the report you'll
note the
economic context and impact of on isn't
interest rates in terms of our
investment returns
you'll see that there has been a
variance and adverse variance on the
original budget that was largely due to
the loss of the airport
dividend and that is for obvious reasons
with the impact that the pandemic has
had on the aviation industry
and finally note that all legislative
and regulatory requirements including
the treasury management prudential
indicators have been complied with so
with that
i'd just like to thank our in-house team
who year after year
work incredibly hard in the background
to make sure that we're compliant and
also
look at investment opportunities thank
you
thank you counselor ross um any
questions or comments from members of
the
executive no
um any questions of clarity more broadly
no um the report is for
noting is it noted
thank you um and moving to um
item 11 on the agenda um councillor
freeman please
thank you deputy leader uh by way of
background the economy recovery plan
was approved in feb 2021 to address
challenges of cove of the coveted
pandemic
and to lead and steer recovery from it
the plan identifies specific actions
required to ensure effective economic
recovery and delivery of a more
inclusive economy
this is not something this council can
do alone
the plan can only be delivered in
partnership with a wide range of
stakeholders
exegen were appointed in jan 2021 to
assess the effects of brexit and kovid
and the kovid 19 pandemic on the economy
of the borough
so we first look at the trafford
inclusive economy recovery plan
the plan identifies a comprehensive list
of actions and initiatives against nine
priority themes
to help steer the economy of the borough
through the recovery stage
the themes are business support and job
creation
transition preparedness trading outside
the eu
green economy sustainable job creation
funding and growth
strategic sites development and job
creation
improving town centres for residents and
businesses and increasing visit the
visitor economy
appendix to the paper provides updates
on each of the actions and initiatives
and provides a red amber green rating
for each activity
regular updates of the plan are made to
the inclusive economy board
under the trafford partnership there
will be a further update on the progress
of the plan to this executive
in january 2022 the plan is a live
document subject to amendments as
priorities and issues
to address our recovery change the
executive is asked to note the progress
of the plan to date and that a further
report will be provided in jan 2022
now let's look at brexit and kovid 19
the economic
impact assessment for trafford the
economic impact assessment provides a
detailed analysis on the potential
impact of brexit and kovid 19 in
trafford
i'm sure you will agree it does not
paint a very rosy picture
in terms of brexit and it will still be
some time before the full impacts of
that are felt
it is estimated the national economy
will be five percent lower in 2030
compared to remaining as an eu member
in terms of kovid 19 national output in
2020
it declined by 10 percent twice the
decline
felt in the financial crisis of 2009.
in addition covid19 is having a
differential effect
across the uk largely due to health
inequalities
social and economic conditions plus the
restrictions we've all been
under the traffic economic landscape
is changing prior to covid traffic
enjoyed low unemployment strong growth
however a significant number of
businesses have been and will be
affected
and the full effects will become clearer
as government support measures
wind up migration rule changes are
reducing the number of eu nationals
living and working in trafford people
who are important to sectors
including banking and finance
hospitality
manufacturing health and social care
the impact upon our communities in
trafford is highlighted by economic
health and social inequalities
claimant count by ward reflects a
typical pattern of deprivation in
trafford
with unemployment concentrated in the
north of the borough
the sectoral impact is a shortage of
skills in manufacturing
export import companies and those
requiring high skilled workforce
including
health and social care leisure and
tourism are severely impacted
as are the emerging issues with regard
to brexit on companies involved in
importing and exporting adapting to the
new arrangements
it is estimated 500 businesses in
trafford
export to the eu which is four percent
of the business base
and 700 companies import from the eu
which is six percent of the business
base
and all are affected by the new
regulations
arising from brexit this is having an
effect on investment in business
and foreign direct investment research
suggests business
investment fell by 16.5 percent in 2020
growing only by only four percent this
year so you can see that recovery is
slow 90 companies in trafford are
foreign-owned
and the threat of these businesses
relocating is absolutely real
in summary the traffic economy shrunk by
10
in 2020 claimants of unemployment
rated benefits almost doubled from 5.5 k
to 9 k
there have been 20 job losses in retail
40 job losses in hospitality and 40
percent loss across a range of
businesses including
transport media and technology gross
value added in trafford is not expected
to recover to pre-code levels
until the end of 2023 in short
covered 19 coupled with brexit is having
a serious consequences
for low-income households and vulnerable
groups
families and children and this is not
helped by the government's
removal from the autumn of the 20 pound
uplift in universal credit
executives are asked to note the
findings of the brexit and covid eia
along with the findings are the the
along along with the the progress of the
uh
economy recovery plan today thank you
deputy leader
thank you councillor freeman are there
any questions or comments from members
of the executive
no um any questions of clara oh sorry
oh and yes councillor coggins
sorry i momentarily promoted myself to
the exec
um i wanted to welcome the progress on
the council business alliance model
mentioned and this i'm working on the
climate emergency i see terms of
reference have been produced it'd be
great if we could see that maybe i could
get a copy or maybe it might come to the
climate commission i guess
and so it was one thing um and secondly
also welcomed the work on the poverty
strategy which as
cancer uh free man has just reminded us
is is he
obviously hugely exacerbated by the
pandemic and brexit
and i see discussion of real living wage
in that context i wonder if the group
has considered
universal basic income as a more
powerful weapon for combating poverty
and inequality
thanks thank you for the question and
do note you have a motion in at council
on wednesday
when uh councillor coggins i'm sure we
all have that debate thank you
thank you um and can we get the terms of
reference
as well as that yeah we can yeah thank
you
um any questions um
of clarity from anybody else no
um so um item 12 is um
urgent items of any other business of
which i have not been
um advised of any
oh sorry is is sorry is item 11
um the recommendation is to note the
paper is it noted
thank you do apologize um yes item
number 12 um
is any other business and i've been
notified i haven't been notified of any
and so i will close the meeting thank
you very much everybody
you